monseigneur jean michel di falco ancien
porte parole des évêques de france
monseigneur merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france une réaction après
cet attentat
vous savez est difficile de trouver les
mots pour exprimer ce que l'on ressent
en fasse un tel comportement une telle
violence hôtel n et on a tous envie de
garder le silence plutôt que d'ajouter
des mômes et elle se tourne plutôt
tourner ou en tout cas pour nous
chrétiens nous tourner dans le silence
vers la prière justement discours de
jean castex à l'instant au sénat il a
adressé un messages oraux catholique
vous êtes homme de foi justement
qu'avez-vous à leur dire vous savez
chacun exerce ses responsabilités là où
il se trouve donc moi je n'ai pas la
compétence pour dire aux autorités de
telle manière elles doivent agir face à
cette menace finalement cette menace
terme au lock jeu en écoutant les
différents commentaires que j'entendais
sur votre tout à l'heure on a
l'impression qu'on est face de la même
façon face au virus un virus invisible
on efface la une est visible parce que à
tout moment un incident un accident un
événement aussi tragique que celui qui
vient de se dérouler à nice peut se
produire ses poses personnes qui étaient
la prime est une pauvre dame de 70 ans
enfin le tour donc ce dieu qui peut
inviter des sites et des bd homme à tout
pour imposer la fois puisque c'est en
quelque sorte c'est bien ce qui se passe
est une une manière de vouloir convertir
par la contrainte à une religion alors
que cette cette pauvre femme est elle à
prier tranquillement dans une église
il est donc ce dieu quel est donc ce
dieu qui peut inciter à la haine à la
violence à la vengeance mais qu'est ce
que c'est ceux qui commettent de tels
actes alors une basilique un les
catholiques ont clairement était pris
pour cible
est ce que vous avez peur non non non je
n'ai pas peur je je continuerai à mener
bon évidemment maintenant on va être un
peu contraint à cause du virus mais
sinon je continue à mener et magie
normalement noranda l'église normalement
célébrer les messes normalement et puis
voilà je fais je fais confiance à dieu
et et si vous arrivez quelque chose mais
ça arrivera mais je crois que justement
ce que nous avons à faire c'est de
quelle manière nous pouvons faire face à
ces événements à cette menace et ce
n'est pas en le vivant dans la peur que
l'on pourra avancer et progresser
est-ce que selon vous il faut renforcer
la sécurité aux abords des lieux de
culte on ça je le pense bien sûr bien
sûr parce que eh ben il faut protéger
les fidèles et donc lieu de culte
d'ailleurs quels qu'ils soient
synagogues mosquées églises enfin
l'ensemble des lieux de culte plus
particulièrement au moment de défendre
puisque il va y avoir des fêtes
musulmanes mais apparemment ils sont
annulés
et puis enfin la toussaint pour les
chrétiens donc la présence dans les
cimetières donc bien sûr que si on peut
permettre aux autres de vivre ces
moments importants sans être sans les
vivre dans la peur est menacée si on
peut aider protéger bien sûr il faut
renforcer la sécurité
monseigneur jean michel di falco je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien porte
parole des évêques de france en direct
avec mon sur rt france